Bruce do you expect art briles to
survive all this I'm not sure I mean I
my gut is he's in he's in real trouble
there uh you know I saw the reports that
yesterday morning that that Ken Starr
was out he would be the fall guy I just
don't buy that scenario where Ken Starr
would be the president the University
and while he'd have responsibility for
what goes on at the school the idea that
there and there's so many allegations
here with baylor football players have
been convicted of rape already you know
there's been issues where there was a
sexual assault report of two players one
of them was a really you know as a
starter for more than two years at the
school didn't look into it or didn't
really do anything about it how our
trials would be able to not have
knowledge or not not have responsibility
when if the if the president is going to
get forced out I mean I just don't see
that dynamic how that works I know
people are cynical may go well the
football coach is the best coach they've
ever had they built the stadium forum
but if it's the level of the president
getting fired and it's it's a it's a
responsibility where there are more
lawsuits in the pipeline coming and I
just I think it's really a stretch to
think that our Briles is not in serious
jeopardy of losing his job because of
all this because the allegations are not
just the allegation but there have been
players who've already been convicted of
rape there are others in the loop it's
not just like hey you can point to this
one one instance I mean that's that's I
think the part that is so troubling and
I think what people have to keep in mind
is it's not the coach's responsibility
to determine okay this this allegation
seems stronger than this you can't take
it lightly in the way that the rules are
set up around you know title nine the
Clery Act there had to be a protocol and
that was not follow
so I mean I think he I think he is in
serious jeopardy of losing his job Bruce
one of the things that gets coaches
fired as bad publicity as bad as the
Baylor story is about player behavior it
hasn't really captured national
headlines it hasn't captured the shows
you can't really put your finger on
because art briles is not nick saban or
less miles as a household name baylor
football is not a household name do you
think the lack of coverage of the story
could almost let this go away over the
next few months and make it be if our
brows makes it to the season he could be
okay I thought it could of that was the
case may be coming out of the season
these last couple of outside the lines
reports were such I opener for a lot of
folks that it was like whoa this has
been going on here that I think it's
kind of jolting for people to see and
that the aspect of this program that was
a doormat for so long and Art Briles
came in and turned it into a powerhouse
I mean they were on the fringe of making
the college playoff two seasons ago I
mean they are a legitimate top 15
program and if in if you were to ask me
which coaches would have been the most
had the most clout at their schools Nick
Saban would have been at the top of the
list Art Briles would be really close to
the top of that list because and more so
than a lot a lot of more a lot of guys
who are more famous coaches because of
the fact that Baylor had been so bad
before he got there and he completely
flipped the flip the program on its ear
now having said all that oh and also by
the way he had the opportunity to get in
the mix for the Texas job and because
you know he wasn't going to he basically
was going to be handed it sight unseen
without interviewing you know he became
he stated Baylor they built them a
stadium I mean all those factors or why
he has so much clout there but again the
details of these these allegations are
so horrific I mean this isn't this isn't
about a program you know where it's
extra benefits or cheating or that kind
of thing this goes so far beyond that
and because there are so many lost
in the pipeline they're already settling
some of them you know the school has
been investigating you know hired an
outside firm to investigate it back in
September after the first you know
Baylor player was convicted of rape I
just think that uh you know it's gonna
it's I don't think this story is going
away and you know we'll see what happens
they said they're going to have
yesterday they put out a statement that
said they will have some kind of mounce
minh by june third I mean so we're gonna
we're going to get some sort of
resolution in the next couple of weeks
Bruce Baylor was top five in the AP poll
I mean there they had a legit shot this
year didn't a Seth Russell's coming back
from his neck injury they have Jared
Stidham a kid actually I did a story on
in high school who's the natural out of
Texas at quarterback as well isn't that
a factor the fact that this could be the
one year where everything came together
in Waco or has it gotten so bad that
that can't even be considered no I mean
look I I think when you talk about the
talent they have I mean they lost the
first round pick a receiver they're
still really loaded at receiver now they
did lose a bunch of good linemen Andrew
billing it was a real impact guy for
them on the defensive line Spencer
Drango you know there was a real
experienced offensive line those are
they're gonna miss those guys but again
I think because of the nature of these
allegations it's forcing them to look
they I think they know I mean I know we
talked about this a minute ago I think
they get that the country is watching
this or at least the country sports fans
now you know Baylor is that story in
college football and remember what that
long ago where you had the Dave bliss
scandal where you had a basketball coach
in a cover-up for a murder on his team I
mean so you know Baylor has had some
real ugly stuff in its athletic
department but now again as you said I
mean this would have been a team that
the top 15 team but you know we have to
see what kind of shape this program is
going to be in you know after after june
third bruce feldman fox sports college
football right on the Dan Patrick show
Bruce let me lighten it up I think it's
about a hundred hundred days till we
kick off the college football season two
part question the the quarterback whose
name we don't know now that what we
could be talking about as a pro prospect
heisman prospect and the best college
football foodtown not best tailgate but
best town to just spend a weekend eating
you know Oxford's really good for eating
Oxford Mississippi I mean there's just
it's it's great southern food it's
definitely high on the list I think
there's a there's a handful of places
you could go to in Big Ten country and
certain certainly an SEC country that
would fit that I mean I would I would
start with Ole Miss just in terms of the
food part of it as far as the the QB
prospect that maybe it would rise up
pretty fast I would say keep an eye on
Davis Webb he started for a couple of
years at Texas Tech he has a big arm
he's very 65 220 coach's kid now he got
injured and then he wasn't able to
overtake the guy Patrick mahomes whose
dad was a baseball player who's really
talented too and he's a little younger
mahomes I think will be an NFL prospect
he has a huge arm homes as younger Davis
Webb just transferred as a grad student
to Cal and I think he's going to put up
big numbers there and I think he's going
to be a guy who's going to going to get
a lot of attention for as the season
goes on and he's the one who's going to
end up replacing replacing Jared Goff
now they don't they lost their top six
receivers they do have some young
talented receivers but I think there's
there's a lot there for NFL people to be
intrigued by Bruce thanks a lot for
calling in and we got to get a road trip
down to Oxford Mississippi it's I
haven't been in about 20 years it's
killer yeah well you know you'll gain 10
pounds to probably take five years off
your life but it'll be worth it wouldn't
be the first time thank you Bruce for
calling in the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience